so today uh we're looking at
software-defined networking and in
particular
the openflow technology you've got
recording this already from richie
mortier what i'd like to do though
is dig into a bit of the details about
how you'd use it
how you would actually code this stuff
because for me one of the fascinating
things about it is
you can write your own switch software
you can write
the brains of um
you can write the brains of a router or
a switch and that's for me
one of the big uh interesting things
about it
and the other thing is you could get a
bunch of software switches
running the overflow protocol going just
on a humble
laptop you can sort of build your own
data center
you can have hundreds of switches
connected to each other and write the
controller
for the full details you should watch
the that's an excellent video already on
your channel
but i just want to recap about the sort
of thing we're dealing with
so key for me in understanding this is
separating
what we call the data plane and the
control plane
so let's imagine we have some bunch of
switches sending data about now switches
are
often pretty simple minded in what a
normal
switch can do so they're connected up in
a topology now normally
you just configure them they go away and
do that thing
maybe you want a little bit more
cleverer control
if we've got these open flow switches we
can add on top of them
the open flow controller so it's it's a
software component that speaks to a
software component
in these switches so if you imagine each
of these switches there's a little
software component in them
and they can speak to a controller
up here now if you think about what a
switch does
it's got two tasks
it's got to move the data about so it's
got to take
packets in and it's got to push those
packets out decide whether it wants to
keep them
or drop them and then move those packets
out and decide
which of its ports it wants to move the
packets out so maybe
it knows that the data's got to get to
here so it's going to move the packets
down here
move the packets down here move the
packets down here
now moving to packets that's the job of
the data plane
when i think about the data plane i
think of it as being very much a manual
laborer it's looking at a
simple set of rules and it's saying
this packet is going to this particular
ethernet address
so it needs to go left picks up the
packet
moves packet done this particular packet
oh that's not from a trusted source
we're just going to drop it
this particular packet we're going to
send it out we're going to flood it out
to
all of the switches that i know so i'll
send it out to everyone
and it's got a simple set of rules it
works with
that's the data plane the question is
where does that set of rules come from
now normal switches have various
algorithms they work with
but in an open flow situation you have
the ability to write your own rules
than to react to unexpected events
so in the open flow situation a packet
comes in
the switch looks at its list of rules
and if the packet doesn't match any
it's going to send up a little query
it's called a packet in event and it's
going to say hey
controller just got this packet i don't
know what to do with it
the controller will look at its software
rules so
it's software you can write in a
standard language
like python and it will say
what to do with that particular type of
packet and then you come up with a rule
so you say
any packet going to that particular
ethernet port or any packet from that
sub network
you're going to follow this and it
replies to the switch
with a new rule to meet what's happening
with that packet
and now the switch knows what to do with
that packet and
all packets that are like that one yeah
so we've got a situation where the
controller can responsively
see a packet where it doesn't know a
rule and give the switch
a new rule so it's a bit more dynamic
rather than being
kind of like card coded or hardwired it
can be a bit more
fluid absolutely and the great thing is
this this can work for switches
and routers so if your topology is more
complex than this
and there's actual uh routing at the
internet protocol
layer going on your controller can work
with that as well
we've talked previously about bowman
ford or dijkstra
algorithm with routing but those always
just work on a destination now let's
imagine you have something more complex
so you think
i've got video traffic which takes up a
load of bandwidth
but i've got my gaming traffic it's got
to be quick but it doesn't take a lot of
bandwidth
maybe you can devote one part of your
network to be in fast and low latency
and another part of your network to be a
little bit slower but it's got a lot of
bandwidth
so you could send your video traffic one
way your gaming traffic
another way then you can add lots of
other things so you could add in
a firewall so that switch can say
this location i trust all the traffic
can come through
this location they can only see the web
server nothing else available to them
this location trying to hack me last
week and everything from there is going
in the bin
something like this it might be
literally my house where my son's trying
to play
fortnight or whatever so he needs the
faster traffic
and every time i hear this knock on the
door saying daddy are you uploading a
video
maybe it would maybe it would make that
go away with it if you had
multiple paths in your house if your
house had a network with multiple paths
you could uh say okay um mine's going to
go
on the slower path his is going to get
the priority there i might switch that
route but anyway carry on
oh yeah yeah it's true actually it
depends what you want yeah he shouldn't
be playing fortnite got him with his
schoolwork
absolutely um so yeah so we've got there
this separation now with the open flow
system
into the data plane which is just
obeying the rules
and the open flow system which is the
controller
which is setting the rules and receiving
these packet in events these
exceptions to the rules one of the
things that's
just very easy to play about is a tool
called
mini mininet and it's i love it it's
just a gorgeous bit of software
um and its job is to create
software switches and software
hosts yeah
so we can set it up in a really really
simple way
and we can just do the absolute basics
and see it working with some simple
commands so okay so let's tie it up
just in a real simple topology we've got
two hosts
and a switch and we can see here it's
added in some links between host one and
switch one
host two and switch one so now we've got
a
really really simple topology host host
connected by switch and now we can issue
commands
as if they've been is issued from a
particular host so we can say h1
ping h2 and what that means in minion x
language is
host one send out a ping packet to h2
not very spectacular but that's using
the proper networking code this
isn't an emulation this is the real ping
command
sending real packets through a real
software switch
it's not that exciting
so let's do something a bit more a bit
more a bit more interesting
so within mininet
we can build up our own topology
so we can actually write
in python the network
that we want to produce it is a super
simple topology but here's our computer
file topology written in python
we've imported some commands from
mininet and
all this says is we're going to add a
host
h1 and we'll assign it to the variable
left host we're going to add a host h2
and we'll assign it to the variable
write house so this is setting up some
python
objects left host right host and
adding them into mini net as host h1
host h2 switch
s1 and switch s2 and now we can add some
links
add a link from the left host to the
left switch add a link from the left
switch to the right switch
and link from the right switch to the
right host so we've got just a simple
line topology
but we could make that as complicated as
we like
and we could do it programmatically so
we could use a for loop to make that
line as long as we wanted and then
there's just a simple
command here to start the topology and
let me just demonstrate how that starts
so i need to stop mininet and
i'm just gonna do a little clear up to
make sure that all of its
all of the uh software switches is
started have gone away
otherwise to be problems and now we can
start
our custom topology there we go and that
has obeyed the code
i've put in here we can do exactly what
we did before h1 ping
h2 and we're sending packets through
just to be clear so this isn't
simulating this is literally
doing this but via kind of virtual
machines almost is it
yeah yeah yeah but virtual switches it's
um it's setting up
virtual switches rooting those um
switching those packets and genuinely
delivering packets so
it's not a simulation it's
um it's january sundance packets now
what we can do with this that ties into
the open flow is we can
ask that those switches are open flow
switches
that means though that's not going to
work
unless we have an open flow controller
we've cleaned up our controller
and now we're going to start again but
we're going to this time say
instead of using a standard switch we're
going to use
an flow virtual switch running the
kernel so switch
o v s k is an open flow virtual switch
running in the linux kernel but when i
start that
off we immediately we have
a problem because we don't
have a controller so i'll start it off
and it's going to say come back there
could not find a default controller like
i said the
the data plane is the manual laborer
the controller that's the brains that's
the person creating the rules
and if we start it like that without a
controller it's obviously it's going to
complain
what we need now is to start the
controller so i'm going to use a very
very simple
demo one this is demo code that comes
with the pox
python controller the job of this
controller
is to catch those packets in events
and provide rules when it gets
a packeting event yeah
so it's connecting to all of our virtual
openflow switches and listening for
those switches
saying oh i've got a packet
and i don't know what to do with it and
this is the software that catches that
and decides on what rule goes with it
here it's just doing some housekeeping
this is from somebody else's tutorial
code by the way i i should say i
did not write this code myself uh handle
packet in so this is the the heart of it
we're going to get a packet in so this
is
an event that happens on the controller
when a packet doesn't match
any of the rules on the switch so here
we've got this packet an event
this line is just passing it
and switching it into the correct open
floor tone
and what we're going to do here we're
going to say
act like a hub so just send it out to
everybody
just a hub the hub's very very simple if
i don't know what to do i'm just going
to send
that packet onto everybody i'm going to
flood it out there
so we need the act like hub code
and this just says resend the packet so
take my packet in
resend it and send it to everybody
yeah so the packet's just gonna flood
out everybody's gonna get it
and it's fine that abs that absolutely
works
on these this type of switch network
so just that simple logic is going to be
enough to get our controller workings
so i've started up that tutorial code
and now
i'll just do a clean up on the mininet
and i'll start
with the mini net minus minus controller
remote and that's going to tell it you
have got a controller
it's running on the same computer and
here we go and we can see
that this has started the topology we
programmed
and this is uh passing
some of things now we can do our h1 ping
h2
and the data is getting through okay so
you might say
so prove it to me is this really going
through the software
so i could say packets is zero
so set a local variable to keep track of
the packets in the class
and then when we are acting like a hub
self
packets is self dot packets
plus one print counted
packets itself got packets
and now start up the controller reset
mininet
so i start up mininet with my custom
topology and now
it's counting the packets i'm still
throwing some dns errors and i'm not
quite sure why
i don't know why it's getting dns
packets but but you can see
it's counting the packets as they come
through this is still falling far short
of my promise
that it can seem like a data center
right still seeming pretty basic
but we can
make more complex topologies
now to do this i'm going to step up and
i'm going to use a different controller
so i'm going to use here
the floodlight controller so this is um
a large bit of software it's getting a
bit old now for in terms of these
overflow controls so you wouldn't use
this
in a production network but it's very
nice just
as a demo bit of software and to
demonstrate to
uh to your viewers how we can get
a group of switches working on
openflow the nice thing about the
floodlight controller
is it's got a web interface if i browse
this web page
on one two seven zero zero one my own
computer
we can see that it's active it's been
running
for 27 seconds and it sees no
no switches and it sees no hosts
let's start up a mini net topology and
let's make it a tree topology so we're
going to run
a more complex topology so my command
here
has started a topology for a tree with a
depth of three
a fan out of two connected to the remote
control using open flow
virtual switches and the version 1.3
open flow protocol with this we can see
that the overflow controller is seeing
seven switches
19 hosts 12 connections and we can see
a topology wired up so we can see that
this topology
reflects the tree that we've set up and
we can be more ambitious than that
so i can set a a slightly
deeper tree have that connect to the
controller
and hopefully the topology will reflect
the increased complexity we've just set
it so it's got
a few more switches and i can push this
quite a long way
so let's say we want to be just a little
bit more ambitious
let's set that those tree parameters a
bit more so get more towards what i
promised which you can have something a
little bit like a data center
in our laptops so i'm going to try the
tree with a depth of four
a fan out of three but otherwise the
same things the remote controller the
floodlight controller we were using
before
so now it's starting up all of those
hosts
starting up all of those switches we've
got 81 hosts
40 switches wired up in
a tree i can say ping all and this will
send ping packets
between all of those hosts
so here h1 is pinging everything
and now if we go over to our
topology and refresh that
hopefully this should start to catch up
and it should work out that we've got
a tree topology can take a little while
when there's so much
data going through so it just take a
little bit of a while to absorb
all of the topology information it's
getting in there we can see
quite nicely can i zoom in
look at that i think that that's
absolutely lovely to be honest i find
that quite exciting
and just emphasize again this isn't a
simulation in a simulation this will be
very very easy
but this is actual packets being rooted
so
if i say that's h48 and if i say h48
ping h5
it's going to send genuine uh pink
packets
down that topology can we use trace
route through it
we can use traceroute but these are all
switches
and traceroute only looks at roosters
so traceroute will always be
very very simple in this because
uh it's only one hop none of these count
as part of the route
if we had a layer two a switch based
trace route
then we could see something real
interesting with that but unfortunately
we don't
well it definitely looks like the data
center's taking shape there on that
web browser for somebody like me as a
researcher this is really exciting
because
let's imagine i have some new research
idea for how switches should work
and i want to experiment with that
in the old days where switches were just
um didn't have this open flow capability
what i would have to do is
persuade somebody i could try it out i
could simulate it
but i don't have to persuade somebody to
build a switch
using silicon tremendously expensive and
then i go
oh you know what my algorithm needs a
bit of a tweak could you build me
another one that does this
here i can experiment just on my laptop
i can write new things into the
controller
i can write uh new algorithms new ways
of doing things
try them out see how it goes in
these software switches and then
buy open flow switches they're just a
commodity product
you can just say buy me 40 open flow
switches
they're already there and i can test my
new
open flow controller in a real network
having tested it
on software switches within my laptop
so it's just a tremendously exciting way
to play about
and learn about how these open flow
switches are controlled
and how you could control them in a real
network
standard uh computer file question now
though if this is all open source i'm
guessing people can go and play with
this now could they
yeah absolutely absolutely i'm go i'm
going to put things
on github so hopefully people could
uh build this software play with it on
their own machines
and say if you've got linux if you've
got ubuntu you can just
uh installing uh mininet it's just a
single command
and you can just play about with it cool
have fun
cool learn about it or make nice pretty
snowflake pictures with your uh topology
oh yeah oh just uh enjoy the fact that
we've got a lovely uh
fractal snowflake like topology
and two that routine table is going to
arrive with green
green's going to say oh you can get to
blue in one
brilliant i've got a cheaper cost to
blue it's going to here
for the first time here a little bit
longer then we've got 60 possible
positions
one we've got a two three out of five
and then they can all go in any